Okay, what's up? Guys? I'm Grant Thompson. The King of Random
And I'm Nate the Jack of Trades. For some reason Fortnite seems to be taking over the world right now
We've seen so many comments from you
Asking for us to do something with Slurp Juice, so we're out here today to do exactly that but first of all Nate
What exactly is slurp juice?
I'm not really sure what slurp juice is
But I know that it's blue and it glows and I think it's used for healing in the game
Glowing and blue. I think we could probably arrange some kind of concoction to meet those conditions.
I traveled to
8 dollar stores, buying all of the blue, yellow, orange, and magenta glow sticks that they have all of you basically bought them completely out and
The basic idea is we're gonna cut off the tops of these we're gonna separate the two liquids
And then just before we go to shoot these things
We're gonna mix them together to get them glowing brightly and then pressurize it in the canister and let it fly. Let's dive right in
Grant-Trick or Treat.
Nate-What a good treat?
Grant-It's just what I always wanted.
Nate-A bunch of garbage
Right now I'm taking the glowsticks which are full of a fluid and a glass tube with a second fluid in it
I'm cutting the top off of the glow stick, pouring out one of the fluids, and the glass tube inside it
Putting that into a jar where I'm just gonna keep it all in one spot
Once I have so many that the glass tubes aren't fitting in the jar anymore
I will take those crack, them open with a pair of pliers and then pour the fluid in the glass tube into the other jar
It's not a very fast process
Oh dang it and just drop this one in and it broke (wow... great job lol)
You know what most of its still in there though, so it's a little bit contaminated
We are outside and not very bright, but we're still in sunlight you can't tell but this is now actually glowing a little bit
but the
activator doesn't get used up when it mixes with some of this glow stick fluid so the activator is still just perfectly good if we
Poured that into here, it would still make all of it glow quite a bit, which is the plan for later?
I actually had the exact same thing happened when I was draining out the yellow ones which is what our yellow activator
Is yellow instead of clear?
This was clear and tell some dye got in it the yellow activator was clear until it got some dye in it. These things happen
Take a look at this guys
I finished cutting open all of the blue glowsticks and pouring the
Liquids into these two different containers this here is the activator which you can see is not contaminated
Nothing spilled in so this is what it should look like very clear very clear liquid now this over. Here is the dye which?
Surprisingly, also looks very clear this will start turning blue as soon as it combines with the activator
So we don't want to fill the fire extinguisher all the way full or there won't be really any room for the pressurized air in
There along with it
So we'll fill the fire extinguisher 60 to maybe 70% full right about it this mark
and that should take about
70% of both of our jars and that means we're not going to use all the food in these jars
Which means we get multiple rounds of ammunition?
As soon as we start pouring activator in we're gonna start getting a nice and blue glow I might just be coming up out of
the fire extinguisher
Whoo I can see it starting to glow all right
Yep, that looks cool. I mean look at that well. Just break for a second check that out. That's cool. Oh
That's a really nice color. Oh, it's getting brighter
all right four correct ratios
That looks awesome. I'm so great. Oh my goodness blue light
That is beautiful check this out check this out look down there isn't that the coolest color?
Glowing blue you've ever seen all right. Let's get this thing pressurized
You can see we put a Schrader valve on the side here
We can attach that to a bike pump and easily press up to 60 psi
Whoa there goes huh, it's shredded the Schrader. I got a backup. I'll be right back
There's our slurp juice
There we go, that was 60
All right our slurp shooter charged and ready to go test one. Let's do this. How's it gonna be awesome, okay?
So theoretically I just press down this lever right here, and it's gonna shoot out a glowing stream of slurp juice
Just let's see if that works in three oh
That is the coolest thing that he's got glowing fluid it just sticks to the wall
You could actually do like glowing graffiti with this thing you can have a glowing graffiti gun how about that?
I think that should be a new thing whoa look look the nozzle is even glowing if you look down in there
You can see a little blue light in the nozzle this just keeps getting better and better. Let's recharge
I'm gonna see if I can draw a little guy here. Oh
I'm losing pressure. Yeah, it's kind of cool. Though little glowing hieroglyphic
Alright, let's add some ambience I
Love that it's like shotgun approach
All right, this is deviant art
Yes
Yes, what I want to say. I want to say some kind of disclaimer, but nothing's coming to mind cuz you should totally do it
Well that was kind of cool Nate. What do you think I think that it's not the most precise way to paint
But it might be the most fun. It'll still be on the wall the blue. Dye
If you remember doesn't really show up as blue unless it's being
Activated by the activating chemical so once this one is dry
It'll be almost invisible
Unless you hit it with a backlight which brings out the fluorescent dye again that means you can literally paint things to be invisible ones
That glow goes away, but hit it with a black light and it's there
I wonder if that's a new form of invisible ink that we could experiment at the future. I like that different colors of the musical
Speaking of different colors we have some of those. I think we're going to be trying our magenta and orange mix now
I'm hoping that one's gonna look like fire coming out of the extinguisher. Let's go crack it open and light it up
It's got a little bit of blue residue it's starting to react with that already
That works whoo Wow look at that that is intense
You know if you don't have access to molten metal this might be the next best thing because that looks like glowing red magma
Maybe this instead of looking like fire coming out will look like molten metal. I love it. Yes
glowing molten metal imagine shooting molten metal like glowing molten metal out of a fire extinguisher, that's what this is gonna look like
Guys you really can't have much more fun than this this should look pretty awesome when this shoots out
I'm expecting it's gonna look like flaming. I'm actually thinking it's gonna into turning green as it sprays out
I think it might look more green than orange. We'll see that would be weird let's find out
One oh
Wow, it comes out orange, and then turns green when it hits the wall it does
That is cool
That's wild in this light, it's almost got kind of a white tinge to it
It doesn't even look quite that green three two one
Yes, that was amazing
I love how you put like a big white "s" up on there kind of like a greenish yes a greenish
White "s" whiteish peach somehow. It's green and peach color at the same time this isn't an S
This is a symbol for hope
You look like a full-on liquid beam of metal, that's
Right there's all raining down behind you all this like molten metal. Yes exactly like that
That's cool.
I Say we mix it into the fire extinguisher and then shoot it Nate I did come prepared
I have a full body paint suit with
Booties and a hood on it and just to make sure it doesn't get in my eyes or mouth
I have some goggles and a snorkel that I'm gonna use hey guys. This is about to happen. It's happening right now
I'm ready! Lets do this.
All right, we are charged and ready to go, let's light this boy up
Ha ha that is epic that is epic oh my goodness you look fantastic that's cool
That's crazy, I love it. It's fantastic
Won grand finale we're gonna pour the rest of this juice down Nate's back. Why not oh wow
So Nate you got a little bit of this in your mouth
Yeah more than I want they tell us about how does that feel it it?
Tingles like it kind of feels like if you had hot sauce in your mouth
You don't taste the burning
But that same tingling feeling but really really strong and it's quite uncomfortable
It says non-toxic on the package
But this isn't something that you really want to play with and putting about we're using gloves
Protective gear we have safety crew medical personnel standing by so this isn't something we recommend trying at home
But it has been a ton of fun. However. It does work great for glowing graffiti
We nose packing it into something like a fire extinguisher or some kind of squirt gun you can probably use a Super Soaker
Go around and paint your room paint your house
And with the blue glowsticks anyway when it dries it'll pretty invisible
Yeah, one note if you are trying to put it in a sort of squirt gun this
Fluid does eventually seem to degrade some types of plastics. I'm not sure which ones
It doesn't do not destroy
Grants gloves look like they're pretty much completely ruined at this point
So your mileage may vary if you're putting it any sort of squirt gun or Super Soaker. It's true
If you look closely at my gloves right now, you can see it's it's pretty much eaten right through my thumb
And the rest of my fingers are really
They've got kind of like that wrinkly
Pruning effect to them so that is definitely a result of whatever chemicals are in this glow stick fluid
But it has been a lot of fun playing with you guys today
We don't recommend that you try this at home, but we're so glad that you join us for this experiment
And we'll be looking for you in the next video talk to you then
Your microphone your neck ha his neck
That's great, let's get this mannitol